French drug Johnson OFI which is busy
working on a corona virus vaccines
coming under huge pressure over who will
be first to get their hands on any cure
while the company now says that they'll
be no advance for any country earlier it
had provoked outrage at home when saying
that the US would get priority because
it funded early research the US
government has the right to the largest
pre-order because it's invested in
taking the risk the US which expects
that if we've helped you manufacture the
doses at risk we expect to get the doses
first I just reminded Santa Fe's
Chairman Serge Weinberg that it's a
profoundly French company he gave me all
necessary assurance regarding the
distribution of a future santa fe
vaccine in France Santa Fe is one of the
biggest players in the race to find a
covert 19:00 vaccine the company has a
long relationship with the US Barda
research organization and in December it
promised Santa Fe more than two hundred
million dollars for research so far it's
given 30 million for the vaccine program
the French government is angry because
it also sponsors the firm to the tune of
tens of millions
yes French citizens what they think I
think it's just business like everywhere
there are a lot of Inca hearing things
going on I think we were not told
everything it's like with masks we were
supposed to get a huge package of masks
and then the Americans took it
originally it's a French company then it
doesn't matter who pays the money it's
still French or at least it should be
for everyone we need to return the money
that they gave us and then it's us first
first we deal with our problems and then
we think of others it's not normal it's
not good it's not possible I think it's
a bit stupid because at this time we all
need to help each other we don't know
which vaccine will work and which will
be available first if either the US or
France finds the vaccine first that
would be a good thing but it could also
be that another state discovers the
vaccine and decides to keep it for
itself
but schmatko said problematic bus system
i find it problematic because i don't
think the u.s. is the country that most
urgently needs with a vaccine france
also has a lot of sick people but i
think that developing countries with
huge populations like india and others
which don't have enough doctors should
be first even if they didn't finance the
development of the vaccine especially
since they don't have the budget for it
you